let's think a little bit about modeling
population and what I have pictures here
are some of the the most Nolan wraps
actually this gentleman right over here
might be the most known person when it's
when people think about population and
the limits to growth of population this
is Thomas Malthus he was a a British
cleric and and and and writer and
scholar at the end of the 1700s at the
end of the 18th century early 19th
century and he really challenged the
notion that you know population could
grow indefinitely and that we would
always through technology be able to
feed ourselves and that really that the
environment would eventually put some
caps on how much or where the population
could grow to and PF Verhulst and I'm
sure I'm mispronouncing his name here he
is a he was a a Belgian mathematician
who read Malthus his work and tried to
model the behavior that Malthus was
talking about that okay when there
aren't environmental constraints maybe
population does grow somewhat
exponentially but then as it approaches
kind of the limits set by the
environment it's going to essentially
asymptote towards some type of some type
of population Malthus in particular he
actually doesn't think it's just going
to be a nice clean asymptote he actually
thinks that the population would kind of
go above the limit and you would have
these catastrophes and then they would
go crashing below the limit and you kind
of oscillate right around the the limit
through these these these catastrophes
as you could tell Malthus was a fairly
optimally optimistic guy but let's go
through a little bit of the math
and-and-and a little bit of the
differential equations also it's not too
these aren't overly hairy differential
equations to think about population so
the first way to think about population
and I'll express it as a differential
equation and so let's just actually let
me just set some variables here let's
say that n is our population so that's
our population and we are going to
assume that n is a function of T so n as
a function of T is what we're going to
be thinking about in this and frankly
the next series of videos so one way to
think about how to model this it's just
so how does
what is the rate of change of population
with respect to time how does that
relate to things and so we could say
okay well what is the rate of change of
population with respect to time so D at
capital n DT well one way to think about
it is it's going to be proportional to
the population so you could say well
maybe this is going to be some
proportionality constant times the
population times the population itself
and this makes sense if the population
is smaller then you're not going to have
as much as much change per unit time as
if the population is larger the larger
the population the more the more it's
going to grow in a particular unit of
time and actually this is actually a
very fairly simple to solve differential
equation you might have done it before I
encourage you to pause this video if you
feel inspired to do so but I'll solve it
right here and you'll see that we get an
exponential we get an exponential
function here for n so let's let's do
that so let's solve this and we'll
essentially separate the variables
separate the end from the t's although
we don't we only see a DT here but I'll
do that in a second so if I divide both
sides by n I get 1 over N and if I
multiply both sides by DT if you kind of
think about the DT is something that you
can multiply so I'm going to multiply
both side armer divide both sides by and
multiply both sides by T DT so I'm going
to get 1 over N DN on the left hand side
and on the right hand side I'm going to
get R times DT R times R times DT notice
I got the DT on to the right hand side
by multiplying both sides of that and
then I divided both sides by and I got
the 1 over n right over here now what we
can do is we can take we can take the
antiderivative of both sides we can take
the antiderivative of both sides and
what do we get on the left hand side
well this is just going to be the
natural log this is just going to be the
natural log of the absolute value of our
population and actually if we assume
that the population is always going to
be
zero then we can actually take this
these absolute value off but I'll do
that in a second and that's going to be
equal to R R times T R times T and then
we could have added a constant here but
I'm just going to do it on one side so
it's R times T plus R times T plus C and
now if we actually want to solve a for n
we could take we could take if this is
equal to this then e to this power
should be the same as e to this power or
another way of thinking about it e the
natural log of the absolute value of n
is equal to this is another way of
saying that e to this is going to be
equal to that lecture let me just do it
this way let me just sake let me just
take E to both the to both make to this
power and to that part that's equal to
that then e to that power should be the
same as e to that power and so we're
going to be left with e the e to the
natural log e to the natural log of the
absolute value of n that's going to give
you the absolute value of n let's just
assume let's just assume and positive
assume let's just assume population is
greater than zero and so then we could
this left-hand side
this left-hand side right over here will
just simplify to N and then our
right-hand side it's going to be well it
could be e to the RT plus C or this is
the same thing this is this thing right
over here is the same thing as e to the
RT e to the R times T times actually let
me do that in that same color e to the
RT times e to the C times e to the C
right I'm just taking e to the some of
these two exponents that's going to be e
to the RT times e to the C and if we
want to we could just say hey you know
what this is still just going to be some
arbitrary constant here so actually
let's just call this let's just call
this C so it's e to the RT times C or we
could say C times e to the RT C times E
e to the r e to the R T and notice so we
have solved the differential equation we
haven't gotten to this kind of less than
optimistic reality of mouths is where
we're limiting it this is just if we
just assume population is going to grow
the rate of change of population with
respect to time is going to be
proportional to population when we solve
that differential equation we get that
population as a function of time
actually let me make it explicit that
this is a function of time so let me let
me just move the N over a little bit so
let me write it this way and of n of T
is going to be equal to this this was
our solution to our differential to this
differential equation
and once again this is going to just
going to grow forever and if we know the
initial conditions and so let's say that
we knew let's say that we knew that n of
0 when time is equal to 0 let's just say
that's n sub-nought so what would C be
well n of 0 and of 0 is going to be
equal to C C times e to the 0 power e to
the 0 power is just 1 so it's just going
to be equal to C so C is equal to n sub
naught is equal to n sub-nought so now
we can even write it that the solution
to this thing right over here is n as a
function of T and as a function of T is
going to be equal to C times or be
careful and not our initial population
times e to the e to the R T now once
again this is an exponential essentially
our population is going to look like
this if I were to graph it it's going to
look it's going to look if that's my
time axis that's my n axis right over
here if I see oh I could say it's y
equals an axis what however I want
however I want to however I want to
denote it so that would be a nought and
just going to grow exponentially from
there and there you know the rate of
this exponential function is going to be
dictated by this by this constant right
over there it's going to look something
like this and it's just going to grow
faster and faster and faster for
ever and ever and ever and ever now as I
mentioned at the beginning of the video
Malthus Malthus does not does not
believe that this is going to be true he
thinks that we're going to hit some
natural limits that are going to start
to constrain the population and so in
his mind a more natural or more
realistic function that to model
population would look something would
look something like this
or even potentially something that you
know you keep growing crashing around
that around that kind of limit and what
we'll see in the next video is that PF
Verhulst actually came up with a very
good one differential equation and
solution to the differential equation
that does model a lot better to describe
that better describes the reality that
Malthus believed that we were in